was wäre ein neuer rekord für die
distanz von 400 kilometern zur
internationalen raumstation iss stadt in
rund sechs stunden und das ist schon
rekordverdächtig wie in russland das in
nur zwei stunden schaffen und diese neue
bestzeit soll bereits im kommenden jahr
2020 war werden krieg zum science
fiction gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann und nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's herr
sie willkommen
der bisherige rekord liegt bei rund
dreieinhalb stunden
doch das will die weltraumorganisationen
der russischen föderation roskosmos
schon im kommenden jahr 2020 toppen
bei der bisherigen bestzeit im juli 2009
10 waren zwei erdumrundungen notwendig
um den raum frachter mit treibstoff und
nahrungsmitteln an bord zur iss zu
schicken
damals hatte die progress kapsel dann
nach drei stunden und 40 minuten
flugzeit am außenposten der menschheit
im all angedockt und selbst das war
schon enorm schnell
die bisherigen schnellsten flüge zur iss
mit dem progress frachtern oder sojus
kapseln benötigen rund sechs stunden
doch russland plant bereits mit
hochdruck eine neue bestzeit schon im
frühling diesen jahres 2009 10 hatte die
nachrichtenagentur tass gemeldet dass
das russische raumfahrt unternehmen rkk
energija ein neues flug muster
entwickelt habe mit dem die iss in nur
achtung zwei stunden flugzeit erreicht
werden könne
notwendig seien dafür auch nur noch eine
erdumkreisung in zwei bis drei jahren
könnte dieser plan umgesetzt werden
mittlerweile hat russland aber verkündet
diese bestzeit schon im kommenden jahr
2020 zu erreichen roskosmos plant in
diesem zusammenhang einen unbemannten
flugzeugs es möglich werden soll das mit
neuer technik zu der noch nicht wirklich
viele details bekannt sind langfristig
hat roskosmos aber noch ein ganz anderes
ziel das schnellverfahren auch für
bemannte flüge dazu der chef der
weltraumorganisation dimitri rogosin
das ist unsere aufgabe für die zukunft
raum fahrerin und raumfahrern müssten
dann deutlich weniger zeit in einem
zitat kleinen raumschiff verbringen
zudem können die experimente und die
dafür notwendigen materialien deutlich
schneller an ort und stelle gebracht
werden diese entwicklung ist wirklich
der reine wahnsinn ganze zwei tage
dauerte der flug zur iss mal
ursprünglich
die schnelle variante für bemannte flüge
dauert übrigens immer noch gute sechs
stunden
sie wird von roskosmos seit 2013
eingesetzt keine frage jedenfalls auch
bei weiteren flügen ins all
während schnellere flugzeiten super
hilfreich gesichert ist der betrieb der
ss die übrigens schon rund 20 jahre alt
ist jedenfalls bis zum jahr 2024
russland hatte er es in diesem jahr
bestätigt an der station festzuhalten
und zwar selbst dann wenn die usa aus
dem projekt aussteigen sollten wir
glauben dass wir die station behalten
können russland plant die ss als
zwischenstopp für raumschiffe zu nutzen
die längere flüge ins all vor sich haben
dazu die mir die prognosen von roskosmos
es ist unmöglich in den fernen weltraum
zu gelangen ohne auf diesem weg treffen
stufen in form einer erdnahen station zu
haben
tatsächlich ist der betrieb der ice es
relativ einfach aufrechtzuerhalten sie
muss einfach stück für stück mit neuen
modulen erweitert werden und nicht mehr
zugelassene module also die technisch
nicht mehr zuverlässig sind müssen
abgekoppelt werden und dann in der
erdatmosphäre verglüht iss fotografiert
riesen krater weltraum wissen von astro
comics tv also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren am kanal distanz bleibt dran